E aí
e eu como eu sou publicitário mas eu
fiz já algumas palestras sobre
curiosidades sobre propaganda mais
aumentar Fei aqui a falar de uma coisa
completamente diferente então se for uma
completa bosta eu vi que tem um tempo
aqui aí eu vou virar um pouco que você
tiver muito ruim pelo menos você sabe
quando que vai terminar tá
eu acho que ajuda é a 7 anos atrás eu eu
comecei a estudar publicidade aqui em
Brasília Eu Tive que trancar porque você
viu uma proposta para São Paulo e enfim
São Paulo o ritmo é completamente
diferente da que principalmente
publicidade então eu decidi trancar e
quando me ligaram aqui da UnB eu achei
que de repente fosse para você lá
entregar um diploma alguma coisa assim
mas felizmente era muito melhor para
daqui falando com vocês no teste e
embora minha mãe preferência de bom
eu ainda não tenho
mas na verdade o convite aconteceu
porque há 4 anos atrás eu tava aqui na
universidade e eu tava contando um pouco
da minha carreira da minha história das
descobertas e uma das alunas na época
hoje uma das organizadoras do evento
chamou a atenção dela algumas decisões e
escolhas que eu tive que fazer muito
cedo eu comecei trabalhando aqui em
Brasília trabalhei em duas agências
depois fui trabalhar em São Paulo
trabalhei em Madrid depois tive uma
proposta para Moscou a trabalho em duas
agências lá que é onde eu tava agora
antes de vir para cá para o Brasil de
novo fiquei quase três anos lá então
muita mudança
muito desafio muito frio se eu posso
falar com certeza por quem já foi na
Rússia sabe disso Adoraria estar de
bermuda aqui mas enfim
e tu já aconteceu começou a acontecer
quando eu tinha 18 anos então foram
algumas mudanças que pra mim na época
eram muito grandes e aliás
desde muito cedo eu
tenho tomado algumas responsabilidades
grandes proporcionalmente grandes para
meu com 12 anos tive uma empresa uma
empresa de duas pessoas era eu já tô 11
anos e o meu sócio de 19 eu
uma empresa aqui que ele digital a gente
fazia sites eu cuidava da parte visual
era diretor de arte e designer e ele
trabalhava como gerente de projetos
atendimento e
o enfim como era uma empresa de duas
pessoas não seja representava cinquenta
por cento da folha de pagamento de
inteira daquela daquele conglomerado eu
tinha que ir em todas as reuniões então
quando ele ia para um cliente ou se é o
briefing tava eu lá com a minha pastinha
para anotar o que que o cliente queria
etc Teve até uma vez que eu lembro a
gente tava na a gente tava na igreja
Oi e eu conheci na igreja e um cliente
ligou para ele tal falou que queria
conversar a respeito de um site de um
projeto Eu não falo do jeito que que era
a gente pegou o carro e foi
Oi e aí chegando lá era a reunião era
numa sexshop
e e eu estou usando foi a minha primeira
experiência numa sexual tive muitas Tá
mas a primeira foi com 12 anos e Bom
enfim como como ele tinha que me levar
para esses lugares a gente enfim como
essas tiveram várias e várias e várias
reuniões é a maioria foi lugares que eu
podia entrar mas a gente teve várias
várias reuniões desse tipo e quando
quando eu penso nisso quando eu olho um
pouquinho para trás
você me fala que eu vou ter uma reunião
com menino de 12 anos de idade eu tenho
que falar para ele do meu negócio e
explicar para ele o que que ele precisa
fazer para mim a marca eu não sei eu ia
rir eu ia sei lá mas quando eu olho para
trás eu não imagino assim eu imagino sei
lá para o alto falando uma voz grossa
com barba cheio de
credibilidade e eu dificilmente
Eu imagino
E aí
é assim
e
Esse sou eu com 12 anos de idade
e O interessante é que assim Bora
aparece aqui eu peguei uma cigarro
esconde atrás voltar com alguém esse
moleque era um moleque que precisava ir
para reunião precisava sentar com o
cliente precisava sintetizar problemas e
devolver com com soluções esse eram
coisas que eu tive que fazer desde muito
cedo e O interessante é que por mais que
eu fosse
assim eu não era isso não era assim que
eu me entende eu não era assim que não
era assim que eu me projetava Tem um
ditado que é muito legal que diz você
deve se vestir para o trabalho que você
quer não meu trabalho que você tem isso
é muito bacana Tem um amigo meu que um
dia eu fui para agência vestido tipo as
latinhas
acho que ele exagerou um pouco mas hoje
ele tá super bem trabalha numa agência
enorme Londres estão provavelmente deu
certo não é o meu lanchinho Mas ele deu
muito certo
e isso é muito legal porque eu me lembro
quando eu tava no terceiro ano com 17
anos eu bom eu já tinha um histórico já
tinha trabalhado com algumas coisas eu
tinha uma coisa aqui que se uma
portfólio que é uma seleção de trabalhos
você faz e eu enviei na minha cabeça
precisava entrar no mundo profissional
urgente eu tava com pressa para isso e
enfim eu comecei a fazer umas
entrevistas e né para mim era uma coisa
super completamente nova tá de frente
com cara que pudesse na minha carteira
super diferença tinha tido
responsabilidades profissionais antes
reuniões sex shops mais tarde frente com
um cara que podia assinar minha carteira
me pagar todo mês era completamente
diferente Nessa bateria de entrevistas
foi um monte de frustração atrás de
frustração assim me achou muito novo é
enfim número que não colocar o cara
daquela idade menos de 18 anos para
trabalhar e tal e
E aí eu vi que tinha alguma coisa errada
assim eu comecei a ver que eu tava
oferecendo um passado o que eu era ou o
que eu fui até aquele momento ali e aí
eu tive um site de falar pouco eu sou
novo eu posso ser muita coisa e o que eu
posso ser muito mais importante do que
eu sou Com certeza então eu tive a ideia
de colocar o trabalho para trás e um
atrevimento para frente então nessa
última agência a última entrevista que
eu tinha que era Inclusive a gente que
eu mais queria entrar agência mais
criativa possível do sócio está aqui o
Ézio agência me sentir bem É eu cheguei
nessa agência para fazer entrevista e a
primeira coisa que eu falei para o
outro sócio André foi olhar o trabalho
um cocô não é terrível mas eu não posso
sair daqui sem emprego preciso tá aqui
eu tenho certeza que eu vou ser um cara
que você precisar aqui dentro Eu tenho
certeza absoluta disso eu não posso
fazer isso emprego e enfim ele pegou o
trabalho começou a olhar folhar eles é
bom Realmente não é tão ruim assim é eu
acho que eu vou ter que te dar um
emprego ele falou exatamente essa frase
no final e deu emprego e dali começou a
uma descoberta minha um grande
laboratório na minha vida frente a
algumas coisas maiores do que eu assim
eu comecei a ver que o que eu sou não
importa o presente ele é passado o tempo
inteiro né a cada segundo o presente
vira passado o que importa é quem eu sou
E quem eu quero ser E como o meu
atrevimento me torna capaz de tomar
posse dessa identidade que eu assumo
para mim tem um anúncio da Nike que eu
gosto muito
O que diz exatamente isso né Eu acredito
muito que atrevimento é a sua capacidade
de
acessar no seu emocional isso
fisicamente e praticamente início que
esse toque aqui se resume em como
atrevimento é construído de matéria é
físico não é um ventinho a gente tem uma
dificuldade de falar entre físico e
emocional Isso parece parece em duas
coisas diferentes é na verdade não é o
seguinte dar uma pílula eu consigo te
fazer feliz triste irritado calmo com
medo coragem com uma pílula que é feita
de matéria eu consigo gerar em você
sentimentos ou seja isso tudo é física
por isso que um cachorro por exemplo ele
sente quando você tem medo
e assim como cachorro Nós também somos
animais então mais do que
comprovadamente a sua postura ou a forma
com que você se coloca e se projeta isso
exala isso é físico isso causa um
impacto nas pessoas têm que ser Cola os
que dizem que os primeiros cinco minutos
da sua relação com uma pessoa vai
definir noventa porcento de como essa
relação é tem alguns inclusive que são
mais radicais e dizem que isso acontece
um aperto de mãos então não aperto de
mão está definido ali como é a sua
relação com uma pessoa a gente ver como
que isso é super super super forte e eu
venho testando isso na minha vida em
vários momentos desde as reuniões com
dente de leite até ter que apresentar a
campanha se para Ministro para
presidente de empresa para Russo na
lista da Forbes tudo não importa nem um
pouco quem Esses caras são o mesmo tanto
que não importa quem eu sou tudo o que
importa ali naquela reunião naquele
momento naquela situação
o nome faço ser é quem eu me coloco eu
me projeto para ser fisicamente e quando
essa projeção acontece você tem
e não tem jeito tanto cachorro quanto O
Bilionário Russo eles respondem a esses
estímulos físicos e é bacana que o
conceito biológico de vida é esse né
resposta a estímulos a cheio de
professor aqui por favor não dá que uma
pedra se estiver errado mas está certo o
conceito pelote de vida resposta a
estímulos é legal que quando você a gera
resposta a estímulos na verdade você tá
gerando vida e vida porque você quiser
você tem esse poder o poder de criar a
vida fisicamente só de se projetar de
uma forma específica outro conceito
físico também é que um corpo grande um
corpo maior atrai um corpo menor isso é
uma coisa que a gente sabe mestre o o
também disse isso aqui
Eu por exemplo atraio esse anel então se
você colocar essa na minha frente para
alguns milhares de anos ele
provavelmente vai se mover um pouco em
volta de mim
quando eu me faço Grande e eu tenho a
capacidade de atrair coisas atrair o que
eu quiser eu passo a controlar eventos e
de novo estudo se estudou em física Você
não estudou em religião e filosofia
geralmente a gente acha que essas coisas
são espirituais ou uma coisa muito longe
né ouvi o toque da Maria Paula por
exemplo até do mestre o parece que é uma
coisa distante mas isso tudo é físico e
acontece fisicamente
Engraçado que
e em todas essas situações quando
conforme eu fui-me atrevendo untando um
passo para frente Isso acabou sendo
motorizado isso foi esse automatizando e
foi aí que é quando você faz isso quando
você faz isso voluntariamente se coloca
à prova ou se coloca diante de desafios
você acaba entrando numa esfera que é
muito estigmatizado é chamada
prepotência
eu te pergunto rápido que reproduzem
esse problema Provavelmente você vai me
dar um monte de sinônimo de arrogância a
de enfim vaidade soberba mas que a gente
esquece de voltar um passinho antes
desconstruir a palavra entendeu que ela
quer dizer prepotência é potência antes
é potência sem ser ainda né E quando eu
entendo que eu ainda não tenho essa
potência eu automaticamente
e entra num processo de humildade ao
mesmo tempo isso é meio paradoxo né mas
a humildade ou uma prepotência ela
precede a humildade né justamente porque
eu entendo que ainda não tenho essa
potência que eu preciso projetar lá né
ainda não possui por isso eu preciso
projetar essa prepotência EA prepotência
uma pessoa prepotente a terrível é
arrogante é soberba tudo isso que a
gente realmente acha no senso comum mas
uma pessoa que tem prepotência que não é
prepotente Mas você consegue acessar
traços essa prepotência é super
importante porque ela consegue motorizar
esse movimento de atrevimento isso é
superimportante
e se você coloca a simplesmente só essa
estrutura é se pode achar que sei lá de
repente você tá passando na frente do
hospital e você vai se atrever a ser um
médico e a sua prepotência vai te fazer
ser capaz de fazer uma cirurgia não é
bem assim que funciona por isso que com
certeza a
última esfera e que faz parte de toda
essa estrutura é competência
e se atrevimento é eu ser capaz de olhar
para uma porta que eu não vi antes por
não me enxergar grande o suficiente e dá
esse primeiro passo a prepotência ela
cria e materializa chão para você poder
andar mas a competência é o mais
necessário para você poder dá movimento
e seguindo é isso o que seria o longo
prazo a competência ela te estabelece
nessa caminhada
é a minha
a humildade deixou bem claro para mim
que dificilmente muito realmente à
tareia de frente para essas letrinhas
aqui mas de costas para elas falando
alguma coisa
e talvez não mas foi justo por causa
desse traço de prepotência e por
motorizar atrevimentos na minha vida que
eu achei que eu podia vir aqui vou lá o
monte de teoria louca trazer aqui para
vocês e podia fazer um Tex era isso
obrigado a
E aí